good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Wednesday you know what that means
everyone humming yes hump someone you
love this week is crawling along it's
getting there
it's getting there it's just one of
those weeks it's not the best you know
it's not the best the whole balance of
the week is when I find fascinating you
know cuz some weeks you know they're the
same every week but the way you feel
makes a difference you know mm-hmm
fascinating it's fascinating stuff it
really is I can't believe that it's
Wednesday two more sleeps til the
weekend
Margaret Joseph's new podcast today
Lauren Elizabeth new podcasts will be
out later today the snatchler new
podcast today and your girl is on it and
you know I just came in like bulldozing
Snatchers like ready to have them on the
defense but you know what at the end of
the day we pretty much all agree because
there's really there's very little to
what no hot takes from last night you
know we'll be recapping it actually at
the top of the show it's our first story
because it's all that anyone's talking
about so much went down on last night's
season finale of The Bachelor but at the
same time like nothing really went down
and when I look at the season as a whole
I'll never be able to get back like the
16 hours I spent watching two hour
episodes it's more than that probably
like 24 hours really really frustrating
yet here we are going to talk about it
for another hour yet here we are what
was here till 11:30 last night snatch
alluring can you believe that who to see
it hate to see well you know what I was
doing that I would have been here it
rather been here snatch luring I was
setting up my new bed right I did see
that I ordered
you know a with a bigger weight limit
metal slats for the inside of me in
Ben's bed because as I said yesterday
Ben snapped our wooden bed slats in half
because he's always jumping around the
bed like an animal so Ben was like I
have to do some work work presentation
like can you just wait to set this up
I'm like no I need to watch a bachelor
so what did I do I set it up myself
because I'm a modern woman and Ben comes
in Luria at the last minute I'm having
trouble with one screwy's if you just
let me do it I'm like it excuse me what
I what what I just let you do it I'm
like let me put the same together my
entire self now you think like you can
come in and help with the last thing
like well you don't even know anything
you don't know anything about these
slots that I built that
he said you couldn't of done without me
and it's like what would make him think
that he could get me to know anything
about these signs I literally know
everything about the slacks I know
everything about their stickers and
their wheels and their tape and the box
and the instructions and he comes into
the very last minute thinking that he
could do everything my god it was so
interesting it was like male privilege
at its finest and I'm International
Women's Month nonetheless how dare a
mere three days after International
Women's Day was cut short and he's gonna
cut it even China yeah hi there he it
was so upsetting to realize that I was
you know married to a cisgender [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we have so much to discuss today I think
we should get right into it I feel as
though a lot of people are watching live
because a lot of people are working from
home due to coronavirus and don't worry
we will have your daily update on how
current a virus is affecting your
everyday life don't worry we will have
that update people are also really
looking for like a debrief into The
Bachelor because there's a lot of things
flying and there's so many memes going
around so many like fake news going
around I don't know what to believe
there's a lot of memes fiying and I
think we need to stop and catch them all
yeah like gotta catch em all gotta catch
it I want to go through some of like the
fan theories I really just heard of wine
did you guys want to hear an interesting
factoid really quickly sure about
pokemons that you might not know about
your two favorite morning show hosts
that you know some kids when they're
kids they like to set up lemonade stands
your girl's set up a stand outside their
house selling pokemon cards so that's
not pretty not like that was like a gift
of choice we had those binders with like
the little laminated one pack of Pokemon
cards apiece Charmander
then we're gonna be to him Charmander I
can't I stand are you were gonna say I
was gonna say that I've heard some
really crazy like theories about what
happened last night and I read one on my
way here that I'm pretty sure is
unfounded but I'm tellin ya and that
man's dating someone from her seminary
oh I didn't hear that I heard that Kelly
was at the show last night because in
the month after he broke up with Hannah
Ann he Peter hooked up with Kelly and
that's why she wasn't that woman hell
all either but they're just gonna bring
her there and not drop that bomb I don't
think that they would know I didn't they
brought her there because they only
referenced her at the top of the episode
and they wanted to cause a mass
confusion because there were so many
theories about what was going to happen
like was Kelly a factor Kelly's follow
all of Peters family on Instagram and
all the Peters family follows her back
so there was a lot of thought about like
Kelly I may think they just placed her
there to like [ __ ] with us
perhaps I'm sure that they did but why
wasn't she at women tell all if she's in
the fold unclear unclear okay let's get
right into it because we can't not talk
about it any longer without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and
that's true but I must rave about a new
sponsor whose product is actually like
really changed my life the hush blanket
love ding okay I've never had a way to
Blake a weighted blanket before him
people love to like talk about how it
really helps them and this box showed up
at my door and it was so heavy and I'm
like what the hell is in this box
it was my hush blanket I keep it on the
edge of my bed now because I got a blue
velvet one and I happen to have blue
velvet pillows on my bed so it's just
like a really snatched look for like the
ambience the function my new bed is
really becoming like a warm place I
would like to spend more time in the
quality of the blanket is really
substantial it's better looking and
better quality than any other brand on
the market they make hutch products make
their products with only the best
material and some of the benefits of
having a weighted blanket or you can
actually get a deeper sleep you can stay
asleep longer it feels like a hug and
it's proven to help people who
experience anxiety and stress I totally
am a believer in the whole science
behind it and they also have a giveback
program at husk blankets so they donate
one in ten adult blankets and one in
sorry we donate one in ten adult link
ins and one in five kids blankets to
charities and shelters in need it's been
a huge part of their brand since day one
and they understand that not everyone
can afford a hush but they absolutely
deserve the experience of a better sleep
maven 100 night guarantee so you have a
hundred nights to test out your blanket
if you don't love it send it back for a
full refund no questions asked if you
feel like it's too heavy or too light
you can change sizes so it's not one
size there's different bear there's
different weights which i think is
really cool yeah I have the hush throw
and it's the perfect size for my bed
it's not too big not too small all you
need is a light blanket the returns and
exchanges process are super super easy
I leave a discount code if you use toast
at hush blankets you can get fifty
dollars off all weighted blankets so
hush blankets is the company the code is
toast for $50 off all weighted blankets
and if you needed to know anything steel
really endorses them I have had to
vacuum my hutch blanket I've had it for
two weeks four times and I literally I'm
getting my dust buster out it's covered
in dog hair it's the only thing filled
would sleep on I love it it's so great
for
anxiety I have been catching a vibe
recently under my hush blanket reading a
book
catching about catching a vibe like and
I just it's the place to be you guys if
you have never experienced a weighted
blanket hush blanket is the blanket for
you it's 2020 catch a vibe not
coronavirus yeah you definitely want to
be catching a vibe right now okay let's
get right into it
season finale thirty minutes in we have
wanna age meant wanna yeah 25 minutes in
we had an engagement between Peter and
Hannah and I was obviously really
tempted to turn the TV off and walk away
and say Oh Peter and Hannah and what a
beautiful couple I hope they have a life
time of happiness and then never hear
about anything ever again yeah it was
really frustrating to watch because when
I first she didn't show up I'm like I
was just taking a turn for them for the
bad and then something really that set
me off was when he when Peter found out
that Hannah and wasn't gonna show up he
goes did some did she does she know
about Madison or does she know about
does she know she's the only one left
yeah like he like he had something he
was hiding like does she know that she
might be winning by default and no one
told her that and I she brought it up at
women tell all but to me like of all the
mistakes he made making it seem like she
was the one for him and not the only one
left is like the most important she lied
by omission like that one little detail
makes the world of difference like she
thought she and I'm sure watching it
back and everyone watch it look it's so
embarrassing like she's over there
thinking like one it's been me all along
he said Mattie home no no Maddie went
home on her own and you were the only
[ __ ] left I would agree with that and I
do think he should have told her but it
was giving me a lot of like Rachael
Peter Brian vibes where Peter left
because he couldn't get down on one knee
and Rachel got engaged to Brian and if
you just watch the show on its face you
would think she just took the
consolation prize but now we know firmly
that Brian was always her first choice
and that story line just had to play out
right but now we know also that Hannah
and wasn't his right so you could have
like made that argument when he proposed
to Hannah and that he was always gonna
propose to Hannah and you know they were
still together now you can make that
argument he was proposing I was like oh
he this is the woman for him and now he
has the space to do that it was only a
20 so I knew that this engagement wasn't
going to last right so then it turns out
a month later they're seeing each other
for the first time can I just say that
the timeline of everything was very
confusing and they kept contradicting
themselves like he said he didn't see
Madison after that scene at the pool but
then he was like I mean
when I saw you I mean we spoke like he
kept contradicting about whether or not
they had seen each other whether or not
they'd spoken to each other at what
point did Chris Harrison go to Alabama I
could have used a more in-depth timeline
they were being intentionally vague
agreed and I would like to know I'm sure
was the first time they saw each other
but I'm sure there were teams flying I'm
sure at some point he got her phone
number I'm sure there was communication
happening and I just would have liked to
know at what point did they speak for
the first time I know she saw him by the
pool for the first time but like did he
never D I'm here when he was still
having feelings for her Allah Ari and
Lauren and he was genuinely surprised
when she came out of the pool so I don't
think that he had seen her right I don't
think he had seen her either but the
first time he sees Hannah and a month
after their engagement obviously things
have been rocky this past month in a
mansion I would like some more details
on whose mansion that was so when they
are a happy couple they have a happy
couple weekends and they get to rent out
a mansion for the weekend and privacy
she's bachelor pay for that yes
Oh like weekends they're few and far
between probably like a month but they
they get a really nice house that's so
nice of ABC to pay for them yeah because
they have to put them somewhere secluded
right and if they're gonna be filming it
has to be nice looking into the Sun yeah
so they have this swanky pad whereas
when a far too far yeah when she no and
when she was crying in the bathroom I'm
like is that it yet so tub when she was
walking through that and I was like is
that a photo booth oh yeah there was a
cave yeah it was a sweet house we should
find it on the toasters already found it
yeah okay so it was very strange and the
reason why they wind up breaking up is
because Peter can't give her his whole
heart and she showed up there knowing
that [ __ ] was wrong they've been engaged
in a month but they hadn't really for a
month and they hadn't really been
speaking or they haven't seen each other
it was just so weird it was weird and it
was like was it like he wasn't being a
good fiance or was he hung up on Madison
or we sit he hung up on Hannah brown
there wasn't a good enough explanation
as to how and when everything
deteriorated in their engagement yeah
and all along I never thought that
Hannah Ann was the right fit for for
Peter but I always really liked her and
I never thought she was a bad person
like even with that Kelsey stuff I
thought Kelsey was really hard on her
she never did anything wrong so she
didn't deserve to be like embarrass in
the way that she was and I never really
thought about it until she said you know
you took away my first engagement for me
which should have been my only
engagement and that was like really
heartbreaking yeah and I felt like a lot
of her lines both at the break-up and
that after the final rose we're like a
little rehearsed like she'd had thought
of what she want never hurts but you
thought of what she wanted to say and it
didn't bother me like I taught you
was really well-spoken and she got out
what she needed to get out she looked
like the absolute [ __ ] send naturally
with her extensions on after the final
rose if I were snitch like I would be
quaking because at dress like if she
ever became Bachelorette it would be
called the snatch lorette well then
that's the whole tragedy here is that if
we learn anything from other seasons
girls like Hannah Ann who get dumped
after winning like Becca more often than
not go on to become the Bachelorette but
now we know Claire Crowley's about right
which we'll get to in a minute um and
she doesn't have that same Perry tellin
she'll have a full life you know she
could maybe go on paradise
she'll be fine yeah but a lot of the you
can get over the initial embarrassment
knowing that they're filming your
breakup you'll probably be the
Bachelorette yeah and I think when
during the breakup she was saying all
the right Bachelorette things right like
the key word then last night she already
knew she wasn't getting it so she was
really just being herself yeah um and I
thought that she handled everything
really well except that I do not think
that she went on that show to get
engaged and I um no one was more
surprised than her when he proposed to
her and you shouldn't be that surprised
no and like she couldn't say no at that
point but I do think she she probably
felt a little stuck let's take a pause
for the sirens
so that whole Hanna Ann saga was sad
made Saturday the fact that she's not
gonna be that's right I do agree that I
don't think she necessarily came on to
get engaged and the only time I can
remember someone being that surprised
when they got engaged was Katherine and
Shana like she really didn't think it
was gonna be her but that wasn't coming
from a place of doubt it was coming from
just like an insecurity like hey Millie
yeah and so like you shouldn't be that
shocked towards the end the last four
three girls like you really know who's
the winner like everyone said when they
would like me in the airport like
everyone knew Ben Higgins was gonna pick
Lauren be like like you just know so it
it should have you know set something
off in her head and it was just so fake
like him calling her dad like don't
bring her dad into this he's a nice guy
it was so sad I can't believe they went
through with all of it the farce yeah
despite the fact that he was clearly so
conflicted and obviously it all crumbled
after the fact and on after the final
rose where Peter was like this process
doesn't allow you to grieve the
relationship of four and being engaged
to someone else it's because when you do
this process correctly you don't really
need to grieve that second relationship
because it wasn't the relationship for
you and when you know exactly what
you're looking for in a woman
you know it when you see it and you
don't wind up with such real strong
feelings for Bo two women yes so it was
just it was frustrating I did understand
when he said that that like Hannah Ann
and I totally agree with him like she is
like everything of the sort like you
don't like he was in a temporary bit of
pain but he wasn't gonna pass up on a
chance of forever with Hannah Ann
because he assumed that he would get
over his feelings for Madison and so
even though he probably you know we
could say he should have not gotten
engaged here considering he was so into
Madison how do you how do you let that
go it reminds me of Brad Womack and
Emily Maynard and even though they
didn't have the strongest connection I
felt all season how do you not get
engaged to Emily Maynard when she is
literally an angel on earth
yeah and Hanna Ann has been everything
for Peter this season she's been very
easy family bar no but like better man I
totally understood why barb liked her
initially but to be such a [ __ ] to the
other girl is so unnecessary and we'll
get to that but but I understood the
love for Hannah and she's a mother in
law's dream she loves her son so much
she's made it so easy she's ready she's
what like I totally get why someone
would love her so much but to have the
alternative reaction to Madison is so
uncalled for and yeah and I'm really
struggling because
I can't like I'm just believing what I
see on TV and as far as we know from TV
people are really really upset at barb
because she came from Adi so hard she
claims that the worst thing Maddie did
was make her wait three hours and not
apologize the three hours think doesn't
really strike me as odd production like
is so long so slow they had that
conversation outside whereas Hannah just
pulled up in a car and walked in it
takes ten minutes to film that but to
have that really boring far head
touching conversation production-wise I
can imagine it taking three hours yeah
so I don't think she'd necessarily owed
barb an apology she was filming no but
that's on Maddie because I said this on
this night so I think when Maddie went
to have that conversation with Peter she
was trying to break up with him trying
to go home and it didn't turn out that
way and then she didn't want to meet his
parents and I think it took three hours
of conversing and coercing her to come
and meet his parents and she didn't want
to be there and the family could feel
that and so when you are three hours
late to meet someone's parents because
you were having a conversation that was
not scheduled
you should apologize for making people
wait when they have flown halfway across
the world so when the ARB explained that
I understood why she acted the way she
acted on Monday night's episode and I
was ready to move on for a minute yes
that's true
that's very true I thought Monday night
she was annoying me but she wasn't mean
and she wasn't what she was on Tuesday
and now that I know why she acted the
way she acted on Monday I agree with you
she was her actions were justified on
Monday and Maddie apparently said that
she wasn't madly in love with Peter and
that she wouldn't be able to accept an
engagement and I feel like that's
something they should ever would have
aired
ya know because they want us to think
that this is like a fair fight so I
understood why barb and maybe Peter has
a history of like just two going after
like what he can't have and so barb is
like you have this angel in front of you
Hannah and like please make the right
decision or what she thought was the
right decision so I'm gonna let her
behavior on Monday night
done but then she went in WWE raw style
against Maddie awful that after the
final rose and I just I can't ever
imagine a world in which you air your
dirty laundry like that on national
television really ideal I mean it Maddie
and Peter have absolutely no future like
when it's such a toxic relationship with
the inlaws especially they're both so
close to their family Chad Prewitt her
dad has been like liking tweets on
Twitter about barb like being so mean to
Maddie like this is so toxic and
toxic of course a couple it's like
getting from Kenny's parents from love
is fun a couple is about the two people
but it's enriched by their families and
for two people who are so close to their
families their families to be going at
it there is absolutely no way this
relationship has legs it is going
absolutely nowhere absolutely nowhere I
wouldn't be surprised if they're already
broken up I mean after last night after
literally barb roasting embarrassing
Madison on national television and Peter
just to sit there like a [ __ ] like what
is he supposed to do seriously I mean
he's he can't talk back to his mother on
TV I would have absolutely no respect
for him and that has like barely his
girlfriend at that point there's
absolutely nothing he could have said or
done I felt terribly for him I felt
badly do but I think he could have
stepped in I mean he yelled at his mom
on TV telling her to stop crying
that wasn't a live show that was just a
family conversation that was beyond this
was with an audience like Jerry Springer
style that's Jerry Springer would you
have even wanted him to say there's
absolutely nothing he could say stop but
but what if it doesn't work out with him
in Madison and then he embarrassed his
mom like that's if I don't think that's
him embarrassing his mom his mom's
embarrassing him I know but like you're
still the child and that's your parent I
know but you know sometimes some people
really need to be reeled in I know but
not on national TV I think he just had
to sit there and I think it was the most
uncomfortable moment of his life I think
mad when when barb said that awful just
came for her and then they went to
commercial break and they were like
we're gonna have Maddie respond and
Maddie literally had the most eloquent
graceful she was like I mean these are
Peters parents and I'm literally not
gonna respond like that was how any
mother-in-law couldn't love her she
could have taken and by the audience was
on Madison sides so that she Madison
could have taken that opportunity too
like roads bar back and let's shoot
facts in her and and have the whole
audience be like Maddie
like she could have done that yeah
because no one was on barb side but she
was very quiet she said out of respect
I'm just not gonna say anything because
this relationship could work out and
then you're the girl who spoke back to
your mother-in-law on television I
thought it was so classy service back
for like how any mother-in-law couldn't
love this this you know faith-based
lovely gem like I I feel like I must be
missing something I'm that's what I have
to conclude with is that there's
something that we're not understanding
because just for for barb to be so
pressed about their different lifestyle
to succeed when she said that after
Maddie like respected respectfully
declined to get into the weeds with her
and she started going and again like
I just didn't I don't understand that I
don't and then I can't verify whether or
not this is true when they cut to the
dad and Chris Harrison was like what do
you think about this and the mom said
something really like under her breath
and mounted a lot of people are saying
that she was speaking it's like a common
Venezuelan phrase saying like say
something bad don't leave me hanging two
people are saying but again she was
mouthing something like that would make
sense yes she said have my back in some
way shape or form I was trying to read
her lips the whole night like that
little barb cam in the bottom left
corner was [ __ ] hysterical I'm sorry
and she was she knew she was on camera
she was really playing up her face like
she's going for for a Daytime Emmy she
was just working so I the I roll the
grin though every time had an clap clap
like she was really she took an acting
class she really did and she was just
taking this all way too seriously
considering like Peter and Madison are
not in a relationship right now they
they barely answered that question um
like you're just go it's like it's two
hours and then you can yell at your son
after I just didn't understand why she
couldn't like hold her tongue back
considering she knew that everybody
disliked her after Monday night's
episode maybe you would take that be
like okay even if she didn't feel even
if she didn't agree with it right could
be like oh okay maybe I was really hard
on Madison everyone loves Madison I'm
just gonna skate through this one no she
dug her ear and hug my son
no she dug her heels in I it was
shocking I've never seen anything like
that on television before like I
literally I had to clutch my pearls I
was in shock and you know what it really
makes you think Peters 28 he's a pilot
he's so good-looking like how are you
single like guys like that don't last
long oh I know why cuz his mom drives
every good girl away yeah yeah it has to
be yeah and even when she likes someone
she's driving them away calling Hannah
and her daughter after they I'm sorry
but like off legally and just like
biologically speaking that girl is not
your daughter like when they get married
she'll be your daughter-in-law but you
did not give birth to her she's not your
daughter
and just the dramatics like Peter comes
home from The Bachelor she's on the
couch like you have to come down when he
said and obviously he was being dramatic
he was like I got engaged and they're
not they should be happy regardless of
who the answer is because it means your
son is in love and he is happy and of
the two girls neither of them are serial
killers they're both lovely beautiful
wholesome girls like right you really
can't lose right so I don't know
honestly in thinking about this there's
obviously no way that Madison and
can withstand this because I don't think
their love was even strong enough to it
withstand the fact that he drinks and
she doesn't
you got alone the fact that their
families are the Capulets and the
Montagues truly I think that eventually
Peter and Hanabi will get back together
yeah well Hannah and dropped it very
small but large Bob he knew exactly what
she's doing that's why I just love like
a calculating queen [ __ ] you know cause
like there's no mistakes made and not
calculating in a negative way tell me
Jack someone who thinks she said you
know there were so many people in our
relationship not even just you and I but
Maddie and then you needed closure with
Hannah brown so that they just really
skated right over that but what I
gathered from that is during the
one-month engagement he told Hannah Ann
that he was gonna have a conversation
with Hannah brown just getting some
closure
you know he's moving on in his life he's
getting engaged like he just wants to
have some sort of closure yeah
she doesn't really just drop that in
real nicely suspect but then Hannah
Brown is in Florida like spending some
time with Tyler see yeah and she posted
something on Instagram I got picture of
her jumping it was like freedom I can't
I can't this too many messages like too
much subliminal like things going on I
hope to see Hannah Brown and Peter get
back together and stay together
I want Madison and Hannah an in paradise
and I hope that Claire Crawley sends
some good men down to Mexico well thank
you for bringing that up because you
know they released Claire Crawley's um
dude because I saw the snatcher posted
it and I I have a very interesting
analysis that I took from the Facebook
group that I would like to give credit
to Allie Cunningham for ready there's 32
guys okay 21 of them have a 10-plus age
gap with Claire so they're over ten
years younger than her 21 of 32 guys 31
of the 32 guys are younger than her Wow
there's one guy he's 42 he's the only
one who's older than her
maybe she prefers a young guy she has
said that she loves a younger guy but to
be honest there's a 23 year old cast
what guys cast for Hannah and in
Paradise and you know he's nothing of
the sort according to his photos but not
but also the biggest news that I saw
from the snatchler is that Tyler sees
best friend matt is going on Claire
season yes if you don't know him he's
just been oh when when Tyler was dating
Gigi he was like sleeping on Matt's
couch he was like his NYC Fred now they
live together he's super super nice and
they do the ABC food tours together and
now he's going on The Bachelor which is
so crazy but not that crazy actually
yeah and it'll be nice for Tyler see
like have a friend who's in it with him
yeah but that actually is pretty crazy
the guy's just I mean all the photos
they always look like for girls and guys
like that they picked him up off ugly
island but they're always end up being
beautiful like yeah you see even the
most beautiful contestants you see their
pictures and you're like who are these
people
yeah it's like they intentionally make
them all look all the guys is a creepy
and all the girls look like hookers they
should do like a short video instead
because the pictures just aren't
capturing that or they should really
hire like Bryant that Instagram
photographer who makes everyone look
sickening like yeah why do they want
their photos to be terrible I don't know
it's so weird when Alexis waters came on
the show thinking about that and spoke
about her experience with the photo
shoot they said her shoes wouldn't be in
it and she wore these ugly like clog
boots and then divas then they got her
[ __ ] shoes in it
it's just it's horrible and if that
picture follows you everywhere like even
when I make guest cards for the show for
people from The Bachelor and I search
them the first picture that always comes
up is that photo even if they were on
five years ago yeah it's so true
Hardwell it follows them this season
with a [ __ ] and I think they
released the photos this morning because
they just want to swiftly move on for
sure they also had Claire on at the end
like yeah they just kicked Maddie and
Peter right off the stage yeah they are
done with this season because now this
is three seasons in a row where we
didn't end with happy engaged couple and
that's I think a lot of the reason why
Claire Crowley I didn't you know after I
when they announced it was gonna be her
I thought they were really trying to
skew older but after seeing the guys
they're all in their late 20s um that's
probably not the case I think they just
really want someone just so they can add
add another check two couples and
getting aged yeah I would agree with
that because they're really leaning into
the couples who are like Rachel Lindsay
is becoming literally the face of
bachelor nation I feel like and if you
like in five or ten years like she could
be the next Chris Harrison yeah did you
see that Chris Harrison was facetiming
with the Kardashians excuse me Kim
posted on her story they had a whole
bachelor watch party they had a cake
with Peter's face on it a cake with Hana
hands face on it and cake with Madison
seis on it I don't really imagine that
being on Kim's story with a cake with
your face on it no I literally can't and
they were having a bachelor viewing
party and then after the episode that
Kim posted a picture of them facetiming
Chris Harrison said getting all the tea
yeah yeah the Kardashians have been
loving the bachelor I love that for that
I had a call I was thinking like just
you know thinking things through as I do
I think that Hanna and will
become a model for Kylie cosmetics or
like good American yeah but I do think I
think that they were leaning into the
influencer life and love that because
they're loving The Bachelor shook so
shook okay
well that's that on that if you want
that's that on that's [ __ ] that on
that if you want more Bachelor coverage
listen to today's episode of the
snatcher
I joined snitch and Nicole it was a
really fun episode it's like an hour
long so go and enjoy
they're so cute I mean I could talk
about the stuff forever so the stature
is pertinent pertinent and snatch their
songs which is a segment that they do
and then they make a playlist on Spotify
with all their recommendations so cute
it's so good the playlist I believe it I
only listened to Marko Spotify yeah and
it's also like this songs that she's not
always story it's just like songs she's
genuinely enjoying love that for her
love that for her so head over to the
snatcher the audio is premium quality
this week you guys recorded in TMT a
headquarters it was I was the producer
producer producer okay are you ready for
our next story sure because in a little
Corona Times news talk shows are banning
studio audiences whoa what made corona
virus outbreak smart talk shows across
the city including ABC's The View and
live with Kelly and Ryan and the morning
toast will tape without studio audiences
because of the corona virus outbreak
page six is told yeah we had to you know
send our studio audience home no that
makes a lot of sense yeah it's I can't
even believe that The Bachelor did two
nights have corona studio audience
totally I think that um it's interesting
to see how certain businesses are taking
precautions and I think something that's
really been freaking me out a lot it's
like ordering takeout and restaurants
and I ate it Seraphine the last night
and I have to give them a major major
like high-five every person in the in
the kitchen I mean in the restaurant who
worked for the restaurant was wearing
gloves
I saw the hostess every five minutes she
was wiping down the railing when you
walk into the restaurant like they were
taking major precautions and it made me
feel really like a lot better wow that's
like literally ingesting it yes yes you
are
yeah it's just so interesting to see
I've got a manicure I feel like that
might be you know I got a manicure the
other day and the place was there was no
one in there but I also went in the
middle of the day because I like to go
when there's no one there and I asked
him if it had been affecting business
and they said not really
it's just interesting like
I hope they're also taking extra
precautions yeah well I wash my hands
right when I got to the manicure place I
got my manicure I went home I wash my
hands again so I was working yesterday
really it was like three four o'clock
just really you know typing away and I
was stuck in my own universe in the
doorbell ring which is very rare for me
um I don't really have guests and you
know Theo popped right up we ran to the
door I heard a female's voice open the
door it's [ __ ] Jackie she's like I
need to wash my hands I was in the
neighborhood and I touched a door and I
needed to wash my hands
can you believe being at can you a mat
like I can't even relate to being that
level of crazy I literally walked into
your building like this with my hands
stuck out of my coat in your dorm and
offered me Purell and I was like no I'm
gonna see if Claudia's home I'm gonna
wash my hands cuz I do prefer a hand
washing I think I was in their house for
five minutes I can I wash my hands twice
no because I I washed my hands when I
got in there then they peed and they
wash my hands and I was playing with
seat Athiya when I washed my hands and
then I want more time on the way out
psychotic psychotic but I'm you can't be
too safe in these times you really can
so I hope everyone's staying safe I'm
glad that they've made this decision to
send home the studio audiences I think
what's so awkward to film a show though
in front of nobody there's no need to be
like hysterical and panic right now but
I do think there are small things that
we could do that would just stop the
spread stop the spread and if you don't
need to be in a place where there's a
lot of people like don't be there yeah
agreed
yeah so next story from one of my
favorite Twitter accounts and also a
news source that I will be citing on the
show it's my absolute favorite Twitter
account pop crave news report the news
that we care about
totally and they always have screenshots
like whenever I post something on the
morning toast Instagram I'm more likely
than not founded on pop crave totally
and I saw this story on their Twitter
and then they were the only place that I
saw this story and I thought it was such
a great story um and I was surprised it
wasn't in my like daily feed of news
meat the first members of Rihanna
Rihanna's venti beauty tick-tock house
okay I heard about this I was so
confused she's starting like a hype
house stalkers explain okay rihanna is
leveraging the power of tick-tock with
the opening of a brand new Fenty Beauty
tick-tock house the home will serve as
headquarters for a rock rotating group
of housemates aka tick-tock influencers
who will produce senti beauty inspired
videos for the popular social media app
this is [ __ ] genius is
basically a branded hype house and in
which no one has done yellow one and
it's it's the next its next-gen I mean
Fanta beauty hasn't always will be like
on the frontier of of beauty because
they're always you know pushing
boundaries and being so inclusive and to
me like this is just the coolest
smartest thing you could do in the
article pop crave has all of the
tick-tock influencers who will be in the
first round of the house we know any of
them I don't know any of them that
doesn't mean anything because one is
named Michaela
there's drawn they have varying amounts
of followers any Combs Savannah Chow X n
um and Michaela did om stating a lot of
these influencers have been posting
videos with fenty and this is just the
next step I think that this is such a
brilliant idea
um and I'm so excited to see the content
that they make and this is why like I
know we all need an album from Rihanna
but she's like so busy conquering the
world it's just it's hard to do both it
really is it's hard to do both she
appeared at the house earlier this week
to kick off its launch and explain the
inspiration behind the idea quote I just
wanted to create a platform for the next
wave of content creators I think our
generation is the sickest the illest the
most creative I can't do it alone so to
join in with the people who are
influencing the world my community my
generation this is like a hug
this is so sick I saw on Brett man rocks
story that she had a Fenty party I guess
what she announced this whole take
talking and she divided a bunch of
tik-tok errs and they were all like
talking with Rihanna I was so cool like
I just love her I love her I love that
it's also influencers and chick Tucker's
who I had never heard of so obviously
not like huge huge huge in the beauty
space it's not like the regular YouTube
EDM centers right cuz I think the point
of the house is to get cool content made
for the Fenty beauty channels and you
don't have to have the most amount of
followers to make like the coolest
content like people like in their
bedrooms being so creative with makeup
like make the stick of stuff and they
get one like yeah I think I mean to me
this is the first I've heard of a brand
doing a tick-tock house and I don't
think this will be the last no now
everyone's gonna do it and it won't be
cool or you know different but as of
right now Brianna's the only one doing
it she's the first one doing it and it's
like the coolest idea I've ever heard
but once like brands like revolve next
totally they should be next or else like
they'll be behind yeah they'll be left
behind yeah
without Coachella this year they
officially postponed it I got an email
yesterday yes it is now in October both
Coachella and stagecoach I don't know
how I ended up on some like golden voice
press email list because anytime their
second announcement I always get the
emails in last minute dinner official
email both stagecoach and Coachella have
been rescheduled to three weekends in
October crazy
yeah but I'm glad for it I'm glad we can
all know if you're making plans you can
adjust your plans and prepare I just
already put it in my planner which is
really annoying oh I don't know if I did
mm-hmm well I'll let you borrow my
whiteout thank you
okay next story Billie Eilish takes off
her shirt to protest body shaming did
you see this I did Miami concert riot
yes she was at a concert and she
broadcast a big-screen video in which
she bared her bra apparently making a
bold statement about the pressures young
women face in the music industry and the
online body shaming that comes with it
fans posted the footage to Twitter where
eyelashes in tonane quote if I wear what
is comfortable I am NOT a woman if I
shed the layers I'm a [ __ ]
though you've never seen my body you
still judge it and judge me for it why
we make assumptions about people based
on their size we decide who they are we
decide what they're worth if I wear more
if I wear less who decides what that
makes me what that means is my value
based only on your perception or is your
opinion of me not my responsibility
Wow crazy though that like all this time
she's never been spotted like in
anything other than like baggy clothes
like really nobody does know what her
body looks like and she like put so much
work and effort into that and then she's
just putting a picture of herself in a
bra like at a concert no but that is
truly these are facts by the way so well
said is your opinion of me not your
opinion of me it's not my responsibility
we make assumptions about people based
on their size me so to you of course
this is like so deep I live for her I
live for her and you know when you think
of the the body-positive icons of our
generation like the Jameela Jamil the
people who are really making an impact
you don't think Billy Eilish but I think
I'm gonna start thinking I'm or anything
and there's more she said you have
opinions about my opinions about my
music about my clothes about my body
some people hate what I wear some people
praised it some people use it to shame
others some people use it to shame me
but I feel you watching always and
nothing I do goes unseen
so well said you use what I wear to
shame me and shame it's true because
it's like Billy Eilish covers her body
but why are you hanging a bra the red
car just taking your clothes off just to
be sexy mo so true like let people live
wow this is so well said living for
Billy eyelash icon yeah icon okay you
ready for a fitting final story Billy
icon yeah I'm ready I'm sorry Jenna
Dewan has given birth to a sweet been
named Callum that's nice I'm really
happy for her I just like don't live to
report on Jenna Dewan I know and I just
feel like I'm always reporting on her
giving birth birth to a sweet baby named
Callum with Steve Kazee and then we're
like who's Steve Kazee Twilight what
else does he do yeah sing does he make
money I get that she's technically a
celebrity but like I don't really get
her whole vibe yeah and I get that like
she was in step up which was iconic
briefly and then she was married and
like people were obsessed with the
marriage but she's not in the marriage
anymore therefore I'm not gonna lie I
don't care who I feel as though she is
someone who is famous famous because
like she has a really good publicist
yeah it was like a public persona and I
get that her talent is dancing but she
hasn't really danced publicly for a
while she hosts So You Think You Can
Dance but she hasn't danced herself no
she has not done I feel like in another
world she would have been a pro if she
didn't marry Channing Tatum and become
like an a-list celebrity I think she
would have become a pro I'm Dancing with
the Stars like up there Julianne Hough
that's a very good call and now she's on
the competing show So You Think You Can
Dance just by the way such a mean name
for a show like you think you can dance
I I actually do think I can dance yeah
that's hurtful very hurtful when you're
it's a show about like you know lifting
up dancers exactly let's take a brief
pause for the siren
okay sorry about that we're back and we
just found out some breaking news that
we feel the need to share with everyone
it's shocking ap has reported that
Harvey Weinstein has been sentenced to
23 years for sexual assaults living for
a living today was his sentencing I
guess it just happened here in New York
he was also like in the hospital
yesterday I hate to see it
23 years do they say which president is
it like a good she like it's not it's
definitely not gonna be go she when it's
rape and sexual assault living living
Wow justice has been served by in the
words of Amanda Bynes bring in the
dancing lobsters bring them in bring in
the dancing theos I can't believe it I
mean this is huge obviously I think that
whether or not Harvey Weinstein had
actually gotten like a fair and harsh
sentence it would have made a difference
in every industry like nobody wants to
be a Harvey wants you now and it's
definitely made an impact on how women
are treated but to actually like get
that justice is never served like we
know that was Jeffrey Epstein this is so
fabulous this is so fabulous I'm happy
for all of the women who were brave
enough to tell their stories and I hope
that this inspires more justice in the
future this all happened so fast we were
literally just talking about Gigi Hadid
becoming a juror yeah I guess the trials
have a quick turnaround yeah but well
they say that's in the Constitution like
you have the right to a fair a speedy
trial um and in the our Kelly
documentary we learned like you can
actually use that to your advantage like
if you want to drag it out like that our
Kelly thing was dragged out for seven
years but I guess Harvey wanted a speedy
trial maybe he thought he was gonna get
away with it maybe it's all behind him I
mean he has for years
loved it by Harvey have a good time in
prison and I just feel like you'll be
really popular there I love the
hierarchy within the prison system like
I don't know if we spoke about this but
Gabriel Fernandez when that uh
documentary became really big it caused
quite a stir in the country and some
girl tweeted and it was never verified
whether or not it was true but I
believed her she was like my mom
actually works in the facility where
pearl Fernandez who is was Gabriel
Fernandez his mom was sentenced to and
she's been getting beat up every day in
the quad you know because it the Gabriel
Fernanda story became such a big story
and I just love the prison systems like
have their own moral values yeah and
it's like if you like our channel Esther
like you're the worst of the worst like
no one will talk to you it's like Mean
Girls
yeah sorry pearl
um okay so that concludes our stories is
that correct that concludes our stories
I did not much Vanderpump rules because
I was snatch alluring till 11:30 I know
and I don't you didn't see me while I
got ready this morning but then I want
to be able to look at it the whole time
and find you in the background no it's
totally fine you really you didn't miss
much but it was a good episode just
seeing all the wedding festivities I
don't know if I thought it was such a
good episode because I was there and I
was like living for like I actually saw
a lot of it happening and was like
wondering what everyone was fighting
about and I was with Kristen that Friday
night when they were at the bells
rooftop and she was talking about for so
long and that's why I was in the
background because I got bored of the
conversation and I started to get a
drink and I didn't realize I just it's
cool to see now the context of what all
these conversations were about because I
didn't know that even Stassi and Kristen
were fighting at that point so it was
really interesting to see it was a good
episode I won't spoil anything for you
Stassi and Beau were on watch happens
live after Stassi was looking like the
snatchler beau said one word the whole
time and they had this like astrologist
like she was this really like spiritual
healer as the bartender and she gave
their their signs and their calendar
like a whole reading and she wouldn't
stop talking and he literally tried to
cut her off 45 times but I think she
could hear him and she was just going on
and on about how their wedding date is
actually like a really cursed day and
they were talking about how Beau's whole
family lives in Italy they're all
quarantined in the redzone they don't
know what they're gonna do about their
wedding but it's not till the fall so
they think they'll be okay I assumed it
was like an April or no Lala's getting
married in April we're in California
someone told me I can't remember where
and also I don't think they told me like
so I could tell everyone yeah but like
no we're crazy okay in the u.s. Wow
that's so crazy I will watch him he can
recap tomorrow fully and they also um
Andy asked what it was like to have
Randall post their entire save the date
on his Instagram with the wedding
password they were so annoyed but they
ended up changing the password and like
it was fine but it was annoying it's
annoying but it's not a huge deal yeah
um so that it's not the end of our show
because today's Wednesday and as you
know we do our dear toaster segment
which is our advice segment if you're
ever looking for advice from us we
always keep an anonymous you can email
us to your toasters at gmail.com
anything from work to friends to wedding
to whatever the weirder the better
always anonymous to your toasters at
gmail.com and before we get into that
Edward do your toaster segment is
brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is the all-in-one for
everything you need to start your
business
domains websites online stores marketing
tools Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business you could
say more and some more with their new
feature of email campaigns you can stand
out in any inbox with squarespace's
email campaigns their all-in-one
platform makes it easy to unify your
brand voice from your homepage to your
emails you can have consistent content
from your website to your email with
powerful editing tools to make it your
own
with customizable layouts you can make
any message beautiful and standout you
have mobile editing too you can send
emails to your customers anywhere
anytime and you can do it all with
Squarespace you can create a beautiful
website if you want to turn your cool
idea into a business showcase your work
start a blog sell products and services
promote your physical business announcer
upcoming event everyone's using
Squarespace including us and we think
that you you need to get on the
Squarespace boat so head to
squarespace.com slash toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
your website use the offer code tous to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain again that
squarespace.com / toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code toast to save 10% percent off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain thank you Squarespace
let's jump into dear testers are you
ready sets jump into it dear toasters
one of my coworkers has been posting her
lavish trips on Facebook but when she
does the rest of my co-workers notice
that the pics look like they are from
Google Images did you go through
something like this
I remember you indifferent to talking
about this once oh really or Shay
Mitchell you know I remember that too
but I remember Dana talking about it
well continue um she will check him at a
place like Greece or Alaska tag the
hotel her significant other and we'll
post photos but we noticed that the
photos she posted of really busy places
like the subway the Trevi Fountain our
hotel there are no people in them like
their stock photos there even a little
blurry so after some digging a cave
reverse google image search very nice
woman of you we did find out that they
are from Google or Pinterest it's so
awkward that we know this and it kind of
seems like she's not even there at all
for example any of us could tag a place
in Spain even though you might not be
there just be in your living room that's
true on Facebook you can do that my
questions are how weird is this to to be
just act like we don't know where do we
call her out one of my co-workers
comforted on a photo of how there
weren't many people and she defriended
her it's always so awkward when she
comes back to work after these so-called
trips I assume she has no clue people
have caught on but she's kind of a
boomer and has boomer friends on
Facebook or oh is commenting how pretty
wow so Joe
I think she likes the cloud or maybe she
is there but can't take good photos and
wants to have good social media presence
what are your thoughts sign to reverse
Google Image Search Queen oh my god okay
this is honestly kind of bad it's not
like she's a millennial who's like
pretending she's living a life that
she's not I think she's just probably an
older person and maybe she is going to
these places and she's like look I'm in
Spain this is what Spain looks like I
think it's very benign and even if it's
not even if she's like putting on a
front that she's living a life that
she's not I don't think she's sitting at
home and saying she's in Spain I think
maybe she's in Spain but where she is
isn't that cute I think this is like
really sweet and pure and I wouldn't
call her out because I think she would
be embarrassed and it's not like she's
your friend and you have to like you
know tell her that what she's doing is
weird like this is your coworker you go
home at five o'clock you don't think
about it again like honestly I think
this is really cute no I mean literally
I had thoughts until I found out she was
a boomer like that changes everything
it's so sweet boomers like barely know
how to use Facebook I think that this is
adorable and I'm not entirely sure
whether or not she's in her living room
or in Spain I'm inclined to believe that
she actually is in Spain but just as
like googling pictures of Spain look
Spain I think it's totally harmless
definitely I'll call her out cuz that'd
be really [ __ ] [ __ ] of you even if
she was like a millennial thirst monster
it's your coworker like mind your own
goddamn business yeah if she was a
millennial thirst monster and your
friend you could call her out but like
as a co-worker you shouldn't call your
co-workers out on personal stuff because
like it's this is business here and I do
think it's like a very innocent thing
that she's doing like first of all who's
even checking in on Facebook when they
go somewhere like it sound like she's
instagramming photos that she didn't
take pretending she's in those places
you know yeah that's that's what's weird
but when it's just Facebook like who
gives a [ __ ] what people are doing on
Facebook right this is so different from
the Shay Mitchell saga yeah which if you
don't recall Shay Mitchell got called
out a few years ago because Shay
Mitchell after pretty little liars
really became like this influencer
travel she has a travel suitcase company
and she was traveling to all these
fabulous places and somebody did a deep
dive and realized that a lot of the
places she was posting pictures from
were photos from like popular
photographers from other instagrams
one of them even had like the mouse in
it like from your computer like um and
she got called out and addressed it and
like that was totally different that was
not like sweetness it like this right
because also like she's making her
living on being like this wander less in
SPO for traveling but it's like oh
you're not those aren't even your photos
and you're not giving credit to the
photographer yeah that
not what this is I think that this is so
cute she seems like a sweet lady agreed
I tell her great but thank you for
writing in
next up dear toasters I have a friend
let's call her Lauren who's been dating
her boyfriend for almost seven years on
Friday night he calls her let's call him
Sebastian
that's a weird random name Lauren and
she said viola and Sebastian totally but
it's like when you're doing like a
random person's like John totally like
Tim yeah one Friday night let's calm
Sebastian was stuck at work so our group
of girlfriends e syllables for you went
out of her dress Sebastian well was
stuck at work so the girlfriends went
out for drinks she was acting a little
off Lauren um so after a few vodkas
Kranz we asked you we asked her what was
good I was I just have been Clyde to say
vodka soda it's a vodka cran
she can't write spell out cranberry but
she's gonna keep spelling out Sebastian
so true okay after a few vodka Kranz we
asked her what was up she finally fessed
up that she found a bra and a thong
pushed under Sebastian's night table
earlier that week and they were not hers
she kept it to herself for a couple days
in soup there was foam but didn't find
anything so when she finally asked me if
he was cheating he tensed up he wouldn't
answer or talk to her for days until
Sebastian told her and that oh my god
that the bra and thong was his he is
sure he wasn't gay and that these
articles of clothing heighten the sexual
experience for him he has a whole entire
jar in that night table full of bras
songs bustiers lingeries and pasties I'm
dead Steen II love Sangay better and I
can't breathe okay
to be honest this is either a really
elaborate lie like what's worse like
getting caught by your girlfriend
cheating or having her think like you
have a weird fetish with thongs yeah I
don't know it's either a great lie but
then he has a whole drawer full of stuff
so I think it's true I think it's true
and I don't want to knock anyone's yawn
no of course not and so this is
obviously like a personal journey that
she needs to go down and is he keeping
them like he likes to wear them during
sexual or he likes his partners to wear
them but I feel like she would know yeah
they've been together for seven years
she would know if he wants her to wear
them or if he's wearing them he says it
enhances the sexual experience but like
he's having sex for seven years so she
would have known if he wanted her to
wear it or if he was wearing a thong she
would know yeah I need more details I'm
sorry on what he's actually doing with
them is he pleasuring himself alone with
them like a sex toy vibe Oh perhaps
and what is the question here like what
should you do or should you even believe
him I think right uh there's you could
find out if he's not being truthful I
think I believe it
I'd say that we believe it um to me this
is more humiliating like having your
your weird you know fantasies exposed
and especially it's something that he's
been hiding from her like he obviously
didn't want her to know to me I think he
would rather fast up to cheating if that
was the case yeah
so I would say that it's true and maybe
she does have some more conversations
with him about it um to try and
understand like you know this he like
maybe it could work for you to like if
you if you knew more about the fantasy
yeah I would inquire further and then
make a decision for yourself based on
your entire relationship not just this
no of course not I just wasn't away
seven years because someone doesn't mean
you didn't expect like yeah but the in
their own private time of course that's
not illegal but it is strange that you
can know someone for seven years and
they could keep a secret so well like
that's what freaks me out it's never the
crime it's always the cover-up like the
fact that you were able to keep
something hidden from your partner of
seven years like means you're good at
lying and that that would concern me
more than anything that's true yes so I
would I would explore more but maybe it
was something that was never meant for
anyone else to know
you know that's possible um okay final
one hello counselors I'm a broke [ __ ] I
started selling my foot pictures online
I created a premium snapchat to get that
cash I didn't use my phone numbers to no
one knows no one I know could find it I
posted the username on my foot pictures
Instagram to alert my followers I just
logged in to check if I have any request
to join the premium snap and I kid you
not one of my best friend's boyfriend's
out of it my friend doesn't know about
my account
no one does because it's a secret please
help do I say hey it's me do I act like
I don't know him do I tell my friend I'm
in desperate need of help wow that is so
difficult wow that really was that's one
of the weirdest ones I've ever read
yeah first I just wanna say I respect
your hustle with you and there are
weirder things you could be doing I
don't think that this is so bad no I
don't think so but now it's like I think
that she should tell the friend but it's
not like her boyfriend's cheating he
obviously just has a foot fetish maybe
the friend already knows that but it's
weird the friend should know that the
boyfriend is looking at her feet that
how close her friends are you guys you
know what I totally disagree that would
really embarrass the
friend because maybe the friend knows
about the fetish and she doesn't want
her other friends to know so like she's
like outing her friend's boyfriend I
don't know just know what's gonna just
keep going I find I would actually just
block him and he'll think that your
account got disabled or something and
he'll go find some other feet and right
point I don't have to worry about your
friend's boyfriend looking at your feet
I would just love a follow-up to this um
on some of the financials like how how
are you making money yeah like what's
the payment system venmo PayPal it's a
premium snap you have to pay for it I'm
so off snapchat these days I don't know
yeah interest on I would love some more
I would love your business plan yeah
I would love the business plan as well
and I love that she is and maybe if you
could give us like a link to your
Instagram I just would want to see it
thanks so much I would love to follow up
and think of everyone these were really
good deer toasters as always definitely
just Block in like kind like the account
was disabled our email account is dere
toasters at gmail.com you can always
email us we will always keep it
anonymous on anything you like so those
are really good ones I appreciate that
thank you guys for writing in and thank
you guys for listening to the morning
shows the millennium morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher public radio IR
Radio cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcast find us the morning
toast maybe you want to subscribe leave
a five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we would
really appreciate it there's tons of new
content out on toast news network this
week maternity leave launches tomorrow
new episodes of mood with Fleur and
Elizabeth and Margaret Joseph's podcasts
are out today the snatcher is also out
today and a brand new episode of day
night with Raymond and Adam so there's
tons of content also patreon of the
morning toast is being updated all month
long so make sure you head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning tous have an
amazing day we'll see you tomorrow bye